and buying and selling used clothing is
one of the hottest online trends
secondhand apparel is estimated to be an
eighteen billion dollar industry one
consignment site called thredUP
is selling more than 30,000 items of
clothing every day John Blackstone shows
us how shoppers are getting more for
less in a massive warehouse crammed with
racks of used clothing
James Reinhardt is a king of consignment
and what you've got here is a thrift
store on steroids basically it's exactly
right we have just tons of items it's
the world's largest online thrift store
Reinhardt's company thredUP receives
bags of used clothing sent in from
people across the country about a
hundred thousand items in a single day
if it's clean and in nearly new
condition it's posted online at bargain
prices the pricing on thredUP is eighty
percent off of of what somebody would
pay in a retail store so it's even
cheaper than the off-price stores
it's incredible value but if it's eighty
percent less than somebody bought it for
they're not getting very much money to
let you sell it ultimately what they
want is to get stuff out of their home
and that's really what our customers
value is the convenience sellers may not
make much money but they do make room in
their closets for more Sarah Jane Brauer
both buys and sells clothes unthread up
i've been a bargain shopper all my life
and this is like the best way to be a
bargain shopper and still get stuff that
feels fresh and new and modern there's
now a wide range of consignment sites
and the competition has never been
tighter the real real targets the
markets high-end this is at Hermes
Birkin bag so a piece like this would
sell for around $38,000 $38,000 Graham
wets Barger leads a team of
authenticators at the realreal who makes
sure expensive handbags watches and
other designer items offered on the site
are indeed real so we know that this is
genuine skin by the follicles and the
pores of the markings the real real
receives about a hundred fifty thousand
items each month
Julie Wainwright is founder and CEO as a
percent of our business fashion
peril is bigger than handbags and shoes
and shoes Jesus man shoes who wants to
wear somebody else's oh my goodness are
you crazy
these shoes are awesome much of the
fashionable clothing that fills
Wainwright's warehouse has barely been
worn people buy something take it home
never wear it never take the tags off
and then it comes here I love talking to
men about fashion yes we have a lot of
things in our closets that for whatever
reason we didn't wear yes women do that
and it's just a factor life and it's a
fact of life that even those paying
thousands for an authentic Swiss watch
still like a bargain and the Internet
has grown into a bargain hunters
paradise Therese Jones is national
business correspondent for USA Today
eBay is definitely the granddaddy of
these online consignment shops I think
it made it fashionable and cool to sell
your things online and it also made it
very cool and fashionable to buy things
that other people had owned before
online resale sites have succeeded
partly by borrowing language from car
salesmen nothing in their overflowing
warehouses is used it is all just
pre-owned for CBS this morning John
Blackstone Brisbane California not youth
pre-owned great story over there